And luckily there's not many houses here, so a bit of playing around,
I think you can get it.
So first, you have to take this long road over here,
because any other way to travel over here is
much longer and then you still need to go back,
so with a bit of playing around, you can find out
you can find out that the next house to visit is this one here.
Then it's almost obvious that you should go up here.
Now here, you can choose to take the fast way to this house
up here or the one that takes a bit longer;
actually, it's better here to go down,
because otherwise, you'll have to visit some of these houses multiple times.
Then you can go back up here, and then you go over here,
and then it's almost obvious, because you have to drive to base, anyway.
That--this is the last one you have to visit,
and then you go back to base, and the total time for this is,
and I calculated this for you as a service,
167 minutes.